Muchas Gracias alcaldesa.
Esta vez sí los he pedido antes de Tal
y he visto 1 en concreto
que es 2024 barra 1 456
resolución plan presupuestario a 2º plazo,
que sí. Que me gustaría preguntaros
que qué se ha tenido en cuenta para realizar
esta previsión exactamente
a ver si sabes cuál te estoy diciendo.
¿Se te suena el plan? ¿Estamos hablando de 700?
Sí, no que es este solo es este.
No es en ruegos y preguntas,
es en Dar cuenta de decretos.
Si puede leer, si puede leer el decreto, por favor
sí, Lele. En 2 024 hay unos cuantos sí.
2 024 barra 1 456
del 14 del 3 de 2 024 hacienda
resolución plan presupuestario 2º plazo 2 025,
2 027, 2 024 barra 3 2, 7 8,
eso son unas previsiones
que se tienen que hacer desde la intervención
en colaboración con el concejal de hacienda,
y son previsiones, ya está,
no se ha tenido en en cuenta nada en especial,
ni no son unas previsiones que habéis,
te habéis puesto 1 2, 3% de su vida
ordenad de todo, vamos,
se Han tenido en cuenta para eh
llegar las esas previsiones,
los presupuestos anteriores
y lo que se está en este presupuesto actual
me vale. Gracias